the climate is changing faster and
faster and Europeans want action the
Paris agreement brought the world
together to fight climate change Europe
can take the lead let's make our economy
climate neutral by 2050 our economy
would grow fossil fuel imports would
fall above all our quality of life would
improve so how can we do it first we
will be more energy efficient after all
the energy we don't use is the cleanest
most of our energy will have to be
renewable driven by the wind Sun will
see we can make transport more
sustainable through clean electric or
fuel cell vehicles when possible and
we're needed by using renewable fuels
industry will change too through
innovation and by embracing the circular
economy for the few emissions we can't
reduce we will compensate 3 forestry
climate friendly agriculture a bio
economy for capturing and storing carbon
underground that's how we can reach a
climate neutral economy
we know it won't be easy we will need to
invest in the transformation taking care
of regions and workers who face the most
change think about our lifestyle choices
but it can be done working together will
benefit us all a modernized economy
cleaner air and environment better
quality of life a healthier planet
[Music]